Gronk is good.
We love Gronk around here
because he's a sports man
you can make jokes about,
even if you don't know anything
about sports.
'Cause you don't really
have to know anything
about sports to get Gronk.
He seems kind of harmless,
right?
Just a lovable NFL star
next door who hates shirts!
He hates 'em! Aah!
Grrr. Maybe he hates Florida.
I don't know.
Maybe that's what he hates.
-Nobody wears shirts...
-Yeah, he thinks...
he thinks he's gonna
get out of Florida this way.
-I'm gonna get out of here!
-Yeah. That's right.
Well, now there's
a fun new article in GQ
detailing Gronk's party rules.
Surprisingly, there's no rule
about having no rules.
There are a lot of rules here.
Rule number three:
"Take off your shirt."
We covered that.
Rule six: "Dance on tables."
Rule seven:
"Just because everyone wants
"to have sex with you
doesn't mean
you should have sex
with everyone."
-(laughter) -HELLER: I wish
I'd known that in college.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
There was no Gronk then.
-Now he's here to tell you.
-Yeah.
Comedians, what are
some other rules to observe
when partying with Gronk?
-Janelle. -Uh, formal wear is
a three-popped collar minimum.
-Yeah, all right. All right.
-(laughter)
Points. Emily.
Uh, no hanky-panky-- you
have to call it Gronky-ponky.
(laughter)
-(applause)
-Mom! Mom!
Come on, Mom!
Mom, just drop me off
a block from the mall!
Points. Kurt.
Uh, when feeding Gronk,
make sure to hold the food
in the palm of your hand
and keep your fingers out flat
or else he might
nibble your fingers
-by accident. -Doesn't want to
bite the fingers, yeah, yeah.